this is a story about a missing volcano
and it's sponsored by morning Brew
there are about 1600 active or recently
active volcanoes in the world and in
late 1808 or early 1809 we're not quite
sure one of them erupted and changed the
world's climate you see when volcanoes
erupt they give off a large amount of
sulfur dioxide gas which then oxidizes
in the atmosphere and forms tiny
droplets of sulfates that we call
aerosols if the eruption is large enough
those aerosols are injected into the
stratosphere the middle part of the
atmosphere where they can hang around a
large eruption whether it's high
latitude or tropical is going to put
these aerosols in the stratosphere and
that will essentially block out sunlight
coming into the planet so that will
cause at least in the summer a cooling
effect this is Professor Rob Wilson at
the University of Saint Andrews who
studies how the earth's climate varied
in the past specifically using tree
rings imagine you look at a stump of a
conifer it doesn't matter if it's Spruce
or pine you can see the Rings very
clearly there's a light band and then
there's a dark band so the light band is
basically the spring and early summer
growth where the cells are relatively
large but then as you get this darker
band what we call the Lakewood this is
the sort of the final months of growth
of the tree of that summer season or
that growing season the the cell walls
of those of those cells are much thicker
and that's where all the density is but
the amount of material in those cell
walls is a very direct function of the
summer temperature and then if you then
have a network of sites around the
Northern Hemisphere and it's essentially
you just averaged them together then
that large scale response to the
aerosols of the eruptions will give you
a nice cold anomaly this has happened
and plenty of times before maybe once or
twice a century for the past thousand
years we see these cooling events in the
tree records caused by large volcanic
eruptions you know Tambora so that's
1815 and then the 1257 events and the
1453 or 458 event but it's seen as the
big ones of the last Thousand Years the
eruption of 1808 or 1809 though was
different for at least two reasons
firstly normally when a big eruption
happens the whole planet calls by about
the same amount everywhere but in this
case the temperature response was weird
so just as an example if you look at the
spatial cooling of 1816 it's pretty much
everywhere not quite everywhere but it's
a sort of hemispheric cooling period
there's a couple of areas where it warms
the 1809 and the 1810 year then you get
some regions that cool very strongly but
some regions that walk and you get these
weird dipoles over North America is a
really good example and actually that
makes it dynamically very interesting
because clearly it probably wasn't as
strong an event as Maybe the 1815 is
Tambora it was strong enough to cause
substantial cooling but then what else
is happening in the climate system that
would create this spatial complexity
secondly however in those previous huge
eruptions we've identified which volcano
was responsible either immediately or
through some analysis the thing that
makes 1808 so interesting is that we
don't know which volcano erupted and
caused the cooling we literally have a
climate Cold Case but we've only
discussed one line of evidence when
there are in fact three lines of
evidence we can use to narrow down our
potential suspects and using these
pieces of evidence it's entirely
possible that this case will be cracked
soon the second piece of evidence lies
near the poles every year fresh snow
falls on the ice sheets of Antarctica
and Greenland the snowfall compacts the
snow underneath and over time those
layers of snow get turned into layers of
ice similar to tree rings there are
distinct layers representing summer and
winter snowfall from each year here and
so by counting layers down from the
surface you go backwards in time but
it's not just snow that you find in
these layers the sulfate aerosols
produced by volcanic eruptions are there
too and so you can see in if you take
down an ice core down through the ice
sheet you can measure the concentration
of sulfate and you'll see there's a sort
of background level of sulfate and then
every time a volcanic eruption goes off
you get a big peak in sulfate so you get
essentially just a little solid thing
eruption being eruption so it's a great
record of past volcanic frequency this
is Dr Andrea Burke also at the
University of Saint Andrews who's A
geochemist in her research she looks at
isotopes of sulfur so sulfate Isotopes
are awesome because they provide this
beautiful fingerprint for a lot of
processes that we want to reconstruct on
the past volcanic eruptions so remember
that Isotopes are variations of an
element that just have different numbers
of neutrons in the nucleus so sulfur for
example 95 of sulfur atoms have 16
protons in the nucleus and 16 neutrons
but four percent also have 16 protons
and 18 neutrons and less than one
percent have 16 protons and 17 neutrons
normally these Isotopes behave slightly
differently a process called
fractionation in a way that depends on
their slightly different masses so
anytime you have a physical or
biological fractionation process on the
Isotopes it follows a very predictable
Mass dependent line one of the few
exceptions to this is when sulfur
compounds are exposed to UV radiation
that UV radiation essentially imparts
this very weird signature that we call
Mass independent fractionation and that
really happens in the stratosphere that
signature that gets preserved in the ice
core so when we look at the sulfate Peak
associated with a volcano we can measure
the isotopic signature so that's the
sort of first order thing but then we
can get a bit more because in in terms
of getting latitude what we find is that
tropical eruptions don't really only
deposit sulfur at the poles when they've
made it up into the stratus because the
poles are really far from the tropics
and we can contrast that with eruptions
from Iceland or from Chaka or Alaska and
in those eruptions you get a sort of
normal isotope signature followed by the
stratospheric component if there is one
and so that's how we can distinguish
latitude as well as as sort of rough
altitude from these sulfur isotrips to
summarize then by looking at the ratio
of sulfur Isotopes in ice cores in the
Years following a volcanic eruption we
can estimate an approximate latitude of
the volcano that spewed those sulfates
out into the atmosphere in the case of
1808 or 1809 this analysis indicates our
culprit was probably near the equator so
that really Narrows things down but to
get a definite identification we need
another piece of evidence in a previous
case this was provided by written
records the huge eruption of 1257 was
for a long time also a mystery but ice
core analysis indicated it was probably
near the equator in a great piece of
detective work researchers then found a
series of writings from medieval
Indonesia called the babad lombok that
described a cataclysmic eruption of
Mount samalas sometime before the year
1300. they suspected this was their
volcano this suspicion was confirmed by
what will be our third line of evidence
a fingerprint as well as sulfates
another trace of volcanic eruptions get
trapped in ice cores tiny shards of
glassy material produced in the eruption
called tephra These are significant
because every volcano on Earth produces
a very slightly different kind of tephra
associate like a real big difference
between like Arc volcanoes and something
like a Icelandic one right so Iceland's
sitting right on your Mid-Atlantic
Bridge whereas with arcs right you think
of the arc volcanoes so all along the
Pacific Ocean essentially you get that
subducting slab and that slab that
Ocean's lab it's not just basal ocean
crust going down on top of that is
um sediments and seawater and poor water
so it's got a lot of different
um stuff going down so you get very
different chemistries and those are
quite easy to sort of fingerprint we
have fingerprints on the crime scene
what we now need is a criminal database
of samples of all the fingerprints from
all the volcanoes on Earth in order to
identify one of them as the culprit but
getting those samples is surprisingly
challenging a lot of times uh the
terrestrial record just under records
right so you get erosion so you'll run
away or it's covered by another one
um and so I think that's really where
the the challenge is is that you can get
you can find heifer and Ice cores
there's an ever-growing library of
characterization of tephras but actually
you can imagine that that the sort of
curation of this library is a a very
challenging thing and it's not complete
because the geological record's not
complete this particular volcano almost
comes down to probably a better look
understanding the geochemistry because
you know there's probably tephra layers
from this volcanic event they can do the
geochemical fingerprint but then they
need to have the same geochemical
fingerprint from a known volcano and if
they don't have it in the database they
don't identify it so some poor geologist
is probably hiking around Indonesia or
the Philippines or wherever the
volcanoes could be and one day someone
will stumble across it sometime soon
then we may have an answer to which
volcano was behind the mystery cooling
of 1809 and if we do then we might be a
bit further along understanding other
mystery events in our past climate such
as the huge events of 536 A.D there's no
shortage of unanswered questions in
paleo climate
at that last piece of evidence in the
scientific courtroom any day now a
climate Cold Case may just be solved as
we've just seen we can't make good
decisions without information to base
them on but staying up to date on
everything that's happening in the world
is difficult difficult unless you get a
package of the day's main news that gets
you up to speed in just five minutes
every day oh would you look at that
morning Brew is a free daily newsletter
delivered straight to your inbox full of
the latest in business Sports Tech
investing you name it all written in a
really engaging easy to read style I've
been getting morning Brew for several
months now and I can honestly say it is
a highlight of looking through my emails
it's informative it broadens my horizons
and it contains a quiz and I love a quiz
for example recently I learned about the
aftermath of Hurricane Ian the collapse
of the micromability sector and the new
nightmarish tool from meta that turns
text into video via AI
ugh it's free so there's really no
excuse to not sign up to morningbrew at
the link in the description and make
your mornings a bit more informed but
thanks to morning Brew for sponsoring
this video thank you so much for
watching the video right the way to the
end I hope you enjoyed this one because
this was one of my favorite stories I've
ever covered not least because of the
cool isotope analysis that Dr Burke was
talking about patrons have access to a
bonus video of her talking about her
research in a lot more detail would love
to include it in this but it would have
made it too long so if you're not a
patron please do sign up you get access
to bonus content like that thank you to
Professor Wilson and to Dr Burke for
helping me with this video do check out
their research at the links below if
you'd like to see me some more stuff
from me then here's some recommended
viewing and that just leads me to say
thank you again for watching and I'll
see you in the next one